I noticed uh Pete Hegith tweeting out his own war crimes here.
Tweeting out just like blown up boats. No arrests attempted.
Just just blow up the boats.
Now, I don't know. I don't know about this. Okay. Have you guys
been watching people blowing up the boats? The thing that I don't
like here, okay, the thing that's like obviously bad is we have
no idea what their crimes really were. Right there. There's not
proof. They The United States just says, "Oh yeah, we had intel
saying this was a drug boat." That's all they say, right? JD
Vance jokes. Hey, um I wouldn't go fishing in that part of the
world right now. They don't they don't show proof. They don't
do anything. Well, this is the thing only is this is sort of
my position is it's kind of like pragmatic in a way that a lot
of populists jive with right now. So, I don't know how much you
could signal against this. I don't know. I don't It's tough.
Like, politically, it's tough. They're American boats, not even
really drug boats. But, I mean, they're bringing drugs into the
country, right? or that's that's the idea.
I really I really hope they're not just blowing up fishing boats
as they're coming into the country. It's pretty crazy. But here,
let's uh let's read what Hegith says along with this. Earlier
this morning, on President Trump's orders, I directed a lethal
kinetic strike on nar a narco trafficking vessel affiliated with
designated terrorist organizations in the US Southcom area of
responsibility. Four male naroterrorists aboard the vessel were
killed in the strike and no US forces were harmed in the operation.
The strike was conducted in international waters just off the
coast of Venezuela. While the vessel was transporting substantial
amounts of narcotics headed to America to poison our people.
Our intelligence without a doubt confirmed that this vessel was
trafficking narcotics. The people on board were narotists and
they were operating on a known narot trafficking transit route.
These strikes will continue until the attacks on the American
people are over. There's a New York Times story about a woman
whose fisherman husband died in one of these strikes. Oh, really?
Okay. Yeah, cuz you you never know like who they bring on board
these things either, which is kind of why you don't do overkill
like just murdering people, right? I don't know. I I have a feeling
that every populace is just going to go based and there's like
almost nothing you can do to to convince them that this is bad,
right? You need like like somebody suggesting, there's apparently
a New York Times article from a woman whose husband was a fisherman
who was killed in one of these strikes. You need that and you
need it to be believable and you somehow I don't know if you
need evidence, you need to somehow like sort of prove it to get
any push back against this at all. Also, Maka Brego Garcia's
MS-13 also happened. Yes, also quite bad. Okay, check out the
Asmin Gold reaction. Thank you very
>> Anybody, right? I mean, so so this is it. So earlier
this morning on President Trump's orders, I directed a lethal
kinetic strike on narco trafficking vessel affiliated with Okay,
he sounds so excited immediately.
He immediately sounds so excited about this, dude. He
He's giddy. >> Designated terrorist organizations in the
USS Southcom area of responsibility. Four male narco terrorists
aboard the vessel were killed in the strike and no US forces
were harmed in the operation. The strike was conducted in international
waters just off the coast of Venezuela while the vessel was transporting
substantial amounts of narcotics headed to America to poison
our people. Our intelligence without a doubt confirmed that this
vessel was trafficking narcotics and people on board were naroterrorists
and they were operating on a known naroterating transit route.
These strikes will continue until the attacks on the American
people are over. Let's watch the video. Okay,
that that boat's going to go bye-bye. I don't know what the So,
what's hitting this? Like, did this get strafed by a helicopter?
Do we have any idea what like the the package is that blew up
this boat? Cuz I don't know. Is it just a Cuz it looks like it
gets hit by like flat, but it's like you just see like there's
everywhere. Looks like a cluster munition. Yeah. Like I don't
know. I crazy. Cluster munitions. Jesus.
I sure wouldn't want to be a drug dealer, guys. >> Oh my
god. That's a that's that's a kinetic solution, I'll tell you
that. So like uh like let's say you blow up all the fentanyl.
Do the fish get high? This guy I mean because I wonder like what
happens right because like I think about this what happens to
the fish like did do they how many fish like how far I wonder
how much it affects the fish. This a shark. Well there's a movie
about that right? There's a shark NATO. Damn. So uh it looks
like there weren't any survivors. Huh? Yeah. Did you see where
furled workers all had template auto replies blaming Democrats
without their knowledge? No, I didn't. I didn't see that. Template
templates auto replies. I don't know what that means. Are you
saying that the Trump administration tried to get emails from
them?
Out of office reply emails. Okay. Okay. Yeah, sure. I could see
that. Uh, sounds sounds like something this government would
do. I heard they also put up notices on all of the all of the
executive department websites like the FBI, like the DOJ website,
a whole bunch of websites basically blaming the Democrats for
the shutdown. Yeah, I I've seen all of that stuff.
It's uh I don't know. It's like embarrassing and it's one of
those things that's overreaching in like the exact wrong way.
Feels like Trump's totally miscalculating there or whoever's
around Trump is totally miscalculating there. Cuz to me, I think
you just start pushing people away, right? you start like coming
off as over overtly authoritarian. It's like a choose your own
hatch act violation. Yes, dude. I I had started preparing something
along these lines. I started looking into it and there's just
been so many Hatch Act violations. The FBI specifically Cash
Patel's FBI, Cash Patel's DOJ, No, Cash Patel's FBI. The FBI
actually came through and they said, "We want to be able to wear
MAGA hats, so we're going to change the rule that says you can't
wear like politically affiliated merchandise." And then they
got rid of the actual like independent office that oversaw this
and and like judged Hatch Act violations within the FBI. They're
just like, "You know what? Actually, just get rid of it. We don't
we don't care about the Hatch Act." [__] that. Democrats
have shut down the government uh government Department of Justice
websites are not currently regularly updated. Please refer to
the Department of Justice's contingency plan for more information.
Department of the HUD the HUD page. The radical left in Congress
shut down the government. HUD will be available uh resources.
HUD will use available resources to help Americans in need. This
Department of Agriculture due the radical left Democrat shutdown.
Okay. Like they can't even make it a little bit neutral. Asmin
after went after Oh my god. Asmin also went after Bill Burr for
Riyad comedy festival today too. It was insane.
That might be interesting. Democrats have shut down. Dude, it's
uh it's crazy. All of these all of these executive uh departments
are supposed to be independent. They're supposed to act independently.
They're supposed to not be political. And that's just not at
all what's happening. At some I don't know, at some point I people
got to start breaking, man. People in the Trump administration
now, even the sickens got to start breaking at some point soon.
All right. Here's them violating the Hatch Act on the DOJ page
about the Hatch Act. No way. That's so meta. What? Democrats
have shut down the government. Department of Justice websites
are not currently regularly updated. Permitted and prohibited
activities. All Department of Justice employees are subject to
the Hatch Act. And
uh oh, US 5 USC 7323A
and 7324A,
which generally prohibits department employees from engaging
in partisan political. It's so meta, dude. It's on the same page.
This is uh this is so cool. I love it. You got You love it. You
love to see it, dude. Amazing stuff.
See what what else Asmin's going to say here. Ah, wow. Well,
there it goes, guys. It gets diluted. There's too much water.
Well, I guess so. Where do you think the drugs in Spongebob come
from? I I guess so. No. Uh, isn't this to? I mean, it it's like
showing war footage. I mean, I I feel like showing something
that's released by the federal government. And I don't think
that's really toos, but uh best use of tax dollars. Oh, I'm a
big fan of this. I think they should do this all the time. I
told you I I It's so obvious what his positions are going to
be, right? Like he's painted himself as every person online who
ever painted themselves as like vaguely libertarian was just
somebody who was like pretending until they felt like they could
seize power in some way or people aligned with them could seize
power. They're like, I don't want the government to do anything
unless it does exactly what I want. then it can do everything.
Okay, they can do whatever. Do we know our military didn't identify
those on board or give them a chance to surrender first? We don't
know that they didn't give them a chance to surrender. We do
know that they've shown no proof of identifying these people.
Uh last I checked, right? They say they identified these people,
but I see no evidence that they
excuse me that they identified these people.
Don't see it happening, man. And that's like you wouldn't even
say that they need due process or something, but like it seems
like a real risk. Like at some point if somehow an American citizen
sneaks onto one of these boats and gets killed and it's confirmed,
right? Like people have to go to prison at that point like and
things have to be fixed. For one of the drone strikes, there
was a record of Americans telling the boat to turn around and
the boat listened and got still got drone struck. What? No way.
Plant dad link. Link right now. Link right now. Link right now.
There's no way that they turn around that they like, "Oh, never
mind. We're going back." And they still get drone struck. That
would be crazy. Yeah. Waiting on that link. I'm gonna pull up.
Uh you've got people that are going out there and they're trying
to send drugs over to the US. Just blow up the boat, man. Like,
I totally agree with this. It's not even a
Why's the argument in not blowing up the boat? Why would you
not do this? Why would you not do this? Um,
I mean, basically just the fundamental liberal premise of that
like people shouldn't be
and that probably here's the real issue is probably everyone
was kind of okay with it happening in the Middle East and they
shouldn't have been so much and now it's really hard to stand
up business on this because
it's probably
arguably about the exact same
as
like drone striking
goat herders in Afghanistan. Like it's not really tangibly different
and people just didn't care then and now it's like well this
is weirder cuz it's closer to North America, right? But it's
I don't know. I don't know. It's probably about the same violation.
Arguably the same violation.
Let's let's check this out. Suspected Venezuela drug boat had
turned around before US strike. White House says more vessels
will be targeted despite unease on Capitol Hill over legality
of attacks. A US military aircraft struck a boat suspected of
smuggling drugs in the Caribbean several times from the air last
week, even though the vessel had turned around and was headed
for shore before the strike began. The boat was hit several times
until there was no movement on board, according to a person briefed
on the incident. The strike killed 11 people aboard the vessel
who US officials said were members of the Trend Aaragua criminal
gang. One second. Oh god, I got to sneeze and then it went away.
As soon as I said one second, it just disappeared. Yeah, this
would be a bigger boat. 11 people. That's That's a big boat.
The new details are likely to intensify scrutiny of the Trump
administration's claim that destroying the vessel rather than
attempting to interdict it was justified because it presented
an imminent threat to the US. Sorry, I got a popup. To the US
administr uh to the US administration, officials have argued
that the president has the power to order military action against
imminent threats to the US without congressional authorization.
Oh, there should be a period here or something. Okay. The revelations
come as US officials said the Trump administration is preparing
additional strikes on suspected drug smuggling vessels in the
Caribbean as a part of an expanding military campaign to target
criminal groups that it has designated as foreign terrorist organizations.
This is so this directly contradicts their their like premise,
right? The fact that the boat So the fact that the boat had turned
and that people briefed on it knew the boat had turned and it
was still blown up directly contradicts. There's no imminent
threat there. They're they're heading for shore. They lose their
not uh not Cass's belly but um Cass's bellum bellum bellum they
don't lose it's not that but they whatever their pretense is
for for striking these boats they just lose it cringingle kesh
that's not what it said just so we're clear you're you're saying
just the New York Times said the boat trying to that's not what
it said right it says based on a person briefed on the incident
right so you'd have to be arguing that the New York Times is
lying that they don't believe that this person and again, if
you're the US government, you you could basically
file a lawsuit for this, right? If they're making this up, the
Pentagon lawyers are telling the admin they're uh the reasons
their reasons for the drone strikes are incredibly shaky and
probably illegal, but they don't care. Yeah. Not shocking. They
they control all of the executive uh arms of government, right?
Sorry. They control the executive. So, and they have direct overt
control over the executive departments, right? like the DOJ and
who's going to even bring a case against them? Like, who who
does anything about this? The Republicans aren't going to do
anything about this, right? There's there's no body that's going
to care about this or is going to actually be able to wield power
against Trump. Well, they forget this watching it back because
usually the the departments under the executive are not directly
influenced or directly controlled by the executive in this overt
way. And Trump has set it up explicitly to function that way
for himself. Right? The only hope here is that the next administration
actually takes action against the previous. I think that has
to happen here. And the funny thing is is like people I've seen
some people suggest that the international community, international
courts could handle this. That's insane. No, you dude, the US
will not allow Donald Trump or Pete Hegith or any major member
of its government to go to the HEG. They will not allow that.
That is not an option. They will absolutely intercede. So, it's
the US that has to hold these people accountable. And I don't
I don't know if there's the political will to do it. Anyway,
the New York Times is citing a source for this. And it's not
like a it's not like a source that they have to leave unnamed.
They're not saying it's like an off thereord thing, right? Like
control F turn. It is an accomplished by the person brief told
us. Oh, wait. Hold on. Wait. What? But was hit several times
until there's no movement aboard. Uh according to a person brief.
Oh, so you're saying that you don't believe that it had turned?
Yeah, maybe, maybe, maybe. I see what you're saying that like
it's it's saying it's not saying the source told them it turned.
The source told them that it was killed like 11 people were killed
and it was the boat was struck several times until there's no
movement. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, sure. Yeah, I give you that. There's
the Verge article here. Discord data hack. Discord customer service
data breach leaks user info and scan photo IDs. Oh, is this gonna
every UK person over who tried to give Discord their picture
to prove that they're old enough to be on Discord? Is is this
all of the Discord?
Uh I know a couple people. Apparently, if you've ever joked about
being a minor in some server that's like 18 plus, you have to
send Discord like your ID to show that you're not a minor. I
know people who have sent Discord their ID to prove that they're
not a minor. One of Discord's third party customer service providers
was compromised by an unauthorized party. The company says the
unauthorized party gained access to information from a limited
number of users who had contacted Discord through our customer
uh support and/or trust and safety teams and aimed to extort
a financial ransom from Discord. The unauthorized party did not
gain access to Discord directly. Data potentially accessed by
the hack includes things like names, usernames, emails, and the
last four digits of credit card numbers. The unauthorized party
also accessed a small number of images of government IDs from
users who had appealed an age determination.
Ah, yes. Exactly.
I know people who've had to do this. I think a lot of people
a lot of people are probably going to be patting themselves in
the back cuz I know people both who have done this where they've
provided their their actual ID and then other people who are
like, you know what, that I am not actually going to I don't
care. I'm just making a new account. So, all the people who made
new accounts instead of giving Discord their information, congratulations.
You made the right call. All credit card numbers and passwords
were not impacted by the breach. Discord says the company is
notifying impacted users now over email. If your ID might have
been accessed, Discord will specify that. Discord also says it
revoked the support provers access to Discord's ticketing system,
has notified data protection authorities, is working with law
enforcement, and has reviewed our threat detection systems and
security controls for third party support providers.
Damn. Oh, Stazzy, you you dodged it. I think the British stuff's
probably a different thing if I had to guess because this is
like an age determination. Appealed aneled age determination.
I don't think this is what happened to the British people. I
don't think so. Okay. All right. I'm going to finish up As commentary
here. >> After I finish up Asmin Gold's commentary, let
me see. Let me see how long my Diddy video is. Let's see this.
Okay. Can this just open? Why are you doing this? Oh, that's
really long. Okay. I might I I might do some diddy coverage after
this, but I'm not going to do it before. We'll go after this.
We'll go start reading the documents. Okay. After the asthma,
we'll finish as
>> Yeah. And they're trying to send drugs over to the US.
Just blow up the boat, man. Like, I totally agree with this.
It's not even a
what the argument in not blowing up the boat. Why would you not
do this? You should immediately do it. Instantly do it. Yeah.
Are you not concerned they show no evidence that these are drug
runners? No, I'm not concerned at all. What do you think? They
show evidence every single time they do a military strike? How
much evidence do you need? They provided ample evidence that
that Kilar Albrego Garcia guy was MS13.
He's got MS13 tattoos that his girlfriend censored on social
media. He's got he's an illegal alien. He's not supposed to go
back to El Salvador because of his connection with the gang.
And then he's also human trafficking. He was a wife beater at
the same time, but somehow people No, don't act like there's
a standard of evidence that would make you accept this. No, don't.
I had to walk away for a second. Holy [__] You just
said like a hundred things that I had no idea about and feel
like I'm super dubious are even true. What? That Yeah, sorry.
I walked away for like 30 seconds and this dude just threw out
a million different things that I feel like you should probably
check. No hard proof of Berggo was MS-13, but the censored tattoo
is kind of sus. Okay.
Do we not think it's a little sus that the tattoos they used
to confirm he was MS-13 were totally bogus? Does that go in both
connect in both directions? Cringle Kesh, right? Like the tattoos
that they used to on his hands to show that it's totally bogus.
They're completely lying.
Those were all claims the DOJ made with what evidence? Where's
the evidence? I heard the human trafficking thing was is that
not just basically bringing his wife from one state to another
or something. Oh boy. Aolitical Hold on. Van Kirk Ascold is not
an a-olitical streamer. Okay. >> Do not call him an a-olitical
streamer. This guy's like the biggest political streamer in the
world right now. What is
>> I can't have a trial a major trial. Not every person
that came in illegally. We have thousands of murderers that came
in. They're going to murder people. They already have murdered
people in our country. So we have to get them out and we have
to get them out fast. >> Really bad guys. But in our country,
even bad guys get due process, right? >> If people come
into our country illegally, there's a different standard. These
are illegal. They came in >> but they get due process.
Well, they get a process where we have to get them out. >> Okay.
Let's talk about the Venezuelan. They get whatever. >> They're
do a process of us kicking them the out of the country. Yes.
who is saying tatto. >> Oh, he had some tattoos that are
interpreted that way. But let's move on. >> Wait a minute.
Hey, Terry. Terry. Terry. >> Yeah. He did not have the
letter MS13.
>> It says MS13. >> That was photoshopped. U. So,
let me >> That was photoshopped. Terry, you can't do that.
Hey, they're giving you the big break of a lifetime. You know,
you're doing the interview. I picked you because frankly, I never
heard of you, but that's okay. I picked you, Terry. But you're
not being very nice.
>> He can't even get his insults correct. I picked you
cuz I'd never even heard of you. I picked you cuz I'd never even
heard of you. I All right, that was an insult. I'm saying he
can't even get his insults correct. I don't I don't know how
that that sentence makes any sense. I can't even lie, dude. It
It used to be I swear there was a time where I thought this guy
was funny where I thought I thought the whole situation was funny
and holy, things spiraled out of control. Okay. Holy.
Um, okay. Okay, Asmin Gold's just repeating, I guess, the the
talking points from the DOJ. I would love to see evidence of
any of the things he suggested there.
>> They provided ample evidence that that Kilar Albrego
Garcia guy was MS13.
He's got MS13 tattoos that his girlfriend censored on social
media. He's got he's an illegal alien. He's not supposed to go
back to El Salvador because of his connection with the gang.
And then he's also here. Okay, that is possibly true. But then
all of the rest of the arguments like actually kind of blow up,
right? If he's if he can't go back to El Salvador cuz he's fleeing
from the gang because he's left the gang, he's no longer on good
terms with the gang. Does that not make him a refugee? Literally,
like that literally makes him a refugee. If he's not doing a
bunch of crimes in the US, then like he is a refugee running
from a criminal organization. Human trafficking. He was a wife
beater at the same time, but somehow people st No, don't act
like there's a standard of evidence that would make you accept
this. No, don't even play that game. We already played that game.
You're making that up in order to obuscate the obvious reality
that yes, there are drug dealers that are coming from Venezuela
and other places in South America to distribute drugs to America.
This is what's happening. And the solution to that is to literally
them. That's the solution. And I am so happy that the government
is I just I just want to know that you're like I I personally
if I was an American citizen, okay, I just want to know that
you're actually them that you're actually drug dealers.
Like that's the concerning thing, right? I
you need some way of doing this of determining things. Like this
is this goes down to this is basically the same thing that was
happening with the IDF in Gaza, right? Is we have no idea. We
have no transparency into their target selection into their what
do you call it their oh their like collateral analysis like analyzing
how much collateral damage could be done. We don't have access
to any of that. So it's like concerning watching you just end
extinguish human life with no oversight. That's bizarre. And
I I feel I feel queasy like signing off on that ever. Hey I yeah
I don't need I don't need Yeah. Proportionality
analysis. Yes. I don't need I don't need you to like keep drug
dealers alive and arrest them. Whatever. These guys are drug
dealers. I I could maybe be fine with this, but I need some I
need some oversight. I need some transparency
cuz I don't I don't like the idea of signing off on just wholesale
slaughter without
anything like that. Bad people are bad though. Have you thought
of that? I hadn't thought of that. I hadn't thought of that.
The his girlfriend censored the tattoo thing was an emoji that
was covering his hands along with text on an Instagram story.
Oh Jesus. I It's just crazy to me that like what I would want
there is Asmin Gold also digging into that a little bit. Could
we get any videos of him digging into that? Like does he actually
look this stuff up or does he just like basically take the tweets?
Is he just right-wing Hassan, right? Everything that people criticize
Hassan for not going in depth, not like reading through past
the the headlines or does he just read the headlines
and regurgitate them? Is he just a propagandist like outright?
Even if they were conclusively drug dealers, still illegal as
far as I've read. Yeah, but here's the thing. Here's the thing,
Porter Beller. It's probably, and I I want somebody to dispute
this. Is it more illegal in some way than drone striking targets
in Afghanistan or Yemen or any of these other countries? Is it
significantly more illegal than that? Because to me it sounds
like once you establish the narot terrorism thing which is probably
in and of itself right and you establish these people as foreign
terrorist organizations which the state part state department
can do unilaterally
then you just get to drone strike these people uh under the same
pretext under the same legal uh legality or legal situation that
you people in the Middle East with or is there something different?
Is there something I'm unaware of there? We don't know any evidence
at this point though. It just happened today with this one. Yeah,
but this isn't the first boat that's been blown up. Watching
it back. This isn't the first boat that's been blown up. Lots
of boats have been blown up. At least three or four now. From
what I recall, there was at least three that I'm aware of. This
one and two more before this. Yeah. So, lots of boats have been
blown up. I don't know, man. It's finally doing that. That's
what they should do. Blow up the boat. They never make it here.
Problem solved. That's it. It's that simple. Extrajudicial doesn't
lead to anywhere good. Of course it does. Absolutely it does.
If it hasn't, then you haven't done enough of it. What do you
mean? Then keep doing more and it'll stop. I guarantee you there's
a threat. The killings will stop once we win the war on drugs.
Okay, guys. We'll stop people once we win the war on drugs. That
can't be that hard, right? It's just drugs. How How hard could
it be to win a war on drugs? Has anyone ever thought about this?
We're just going to kill people until the drugs stop, guys. Guys,
war. It's It's just a war. How hard is it to win a war on terrorism
or drugs? Fighting wars on ideas is a really good idea. I think
I think I've heard that a war on an idea, a war on a concept.
Yeah, you definitely can't justify that happening forever. Jeez.
Threat to the common good. Yeah, using force will stop it. Yeah,
absolutely.
>> It's crazy. What are you talking about? How do you think
you win a war? How do you think you appro How do you think that
you stop anybody who's trying to I'm just I'm watching his chat
and really hoping anybody points out the war on drugs. How do
you think the war on drugs went? How do you think that was? How
do you think that was? Asmin Gold >> negatively affect
you and negatively affect the country. >> Does Asmin Gold
realize what the purpose of this is? Like the purpose of this
is regime change in God. It's Venezuela, right? It is Venezuela.
It is. It's got to be Venezuela. I realize this is off the Hold
on. Hold on. Leader. Leader. Leader. Leader. Yes. Yes. Okay.
It is Venezuela.
I I've been doing this swap of Venezuela and um Argentina. in
my head and I I don't know why. Okay, I know Argentina, libertarian
guy who crashed the country.
Venezuela, communist guy. Okay, follow up of Chavez. I got it.
I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. How do you stop that?
You duh. >> Wow. What else do you do? You're going to go
sit down and talk with them? No. But yeah. Yeah. How to stop
a mosquito? Yeah. How do you stop a mosquito? But it's against
the law, nerd. Who made up the law? Who decides what law it is?
Yeah, but what if they haven't read it? Mockingb bird. Well,
I don't know about that. I have no idea about that. How many
people have those died by narcotics? Deleting 10 criminals saves
thousands, tens of thousands. Oh, it does. I mean, you can make
I mean, there's a lot. There is no moral justification to allowing
any of these drug dealers to get to Oh, dude. This is going to
this is the part where it's like impossible to win against any
populist right-wing type who believes in this stuff is they're
going to see that is like every time you kill like 10 drug dealers,
you save 100 Americans. That's the calculus they're all operating
under and they will continue to operate that way. It's the calculus
that let them drone strike the Middle East for years and years
and years, right? Every person you kill there is like an American
saved and that's why it's all okay >> to America. uh there
is no legal or moral just or there might be a legal justification
but there's no moral justification at all in my mind uh like
in in this is the way that I look at pretty much everything is
I look at what is the best thing to do for the most people that
ensures the safety of law-abiding citizens and I think about
what that thing is and then I apply that thing to real life and
I don't really think about the best interest of the drug dealers
I don't think about the best interest of the criminals I don't
think about the best interest of a murderer or a what happens
to them isn't important to me. It doesn't matter. Uh what does
matter is what happens to average citizens that are trying to
live their lives. And I think that mercy to the cruel is cruelty
to the innocent.
That's what happens.
And and I I I'm very glad that now we're finally seeing things
change.
I'm glad to see this. Hopefully they keep doing it. I'll read
a few comments about this. how you uh sometimes there's got to
be like sinister people behind the the Trump admin who are like
actually puppeting this like puppeteering right now, right? It
has to be cuz this is how you manufacture consent for a ground
invasion of Venezuela. Like they have they have the flotilla
there. They have ships that are capable of amphibious assaults
with hundreds of marines around. Right. I I feel like you do
it this way. You say and then you get people to watch the left
like get upset about this. Watch Democrats get upset about this.
Watch anybody who understands like history get upset about this.
And they're going to use that as a way to manufacture consent
to go into Venezuela and do regime change. No, we got it a little
bit female. Little bit. Little bit. But I dude, it's uh this
is like the whole just so we're all clear. This this is the goal
is just to get Maduro out. They want Maduro out. They want to
control that oil. Cheap oil for all. Let's go >> about
this. You're saying it like it was 100% drug dealers, but what
if it was not? You just killed random people. Yeah, it happens
all the time. That's what happens whenever you're in a war. That's
what happens whenever you protect your country. Yeah, of course.
You think we didn't accidentally kill people in Vietnam? We bombed
Dresden in World War II. You think every single person was a
an armed combatant that we Yeah. This is just like Dresden, right?
This is just like Dresden. This is the basically the same thing
as Dresden, guys. Venezuela presents a threat to North America
in the same way that Naz Germany presented a threat to all of
Europe. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> We nuked and >> that's
like the same That's like the same calculus. Oh, I just muted
this. >> Yeah, of course. You think we didn't accidentally
kill people in Vietnam? We bombed Dresden in World War II. You
think every single person was a an armed combatant that we nuked?
Do the drug runners represent the country's government? I mean,
I think the current admin is trying to argue they do somehow.
Yes, that that is the thing is they are saying directly I watched
a video on this. They have like a name They have a name for the
cartel for the the joint, you know, the joint interest of the
cartel and the government that they say they all participate
in. I wouldn't be shocked if the government takes like a a taste
of the profits from drug running, right? Wouldn't be shocking
to me. But that is what the Trump administration has said and
I believe they placed insane bounties on like what's the bounty
Nicholas
Maduro? I think Maduro's got like a hundred million $50 million
bounty on him. $50 million bounty. See, reward poster English.
$50 million US for information leading to the arrest and or conviction
of the leader of the specially designated global terrorist cartel,
Deosles.
This is what is deosles. This is uh I can't remember the name
of it now. It's like something of the sun. Oh, cartel of the
sun. Yeah, cartel of the suns. Cartel of the five sons. Something
like this. Does Trump think this tattoo is real, too? What is
this? Hold on. Okay. Okay. Okay, dude. He might. And he's he's
obviously approaching a level of sinility where he might actually
check his hand. He might look at this image for real. Like if
you showed him this image, I feel like he would check his hand.
He'd be like, "Wait, what? Wait, huh? Yeah. Why did I get that?
Why? What? What?" Rough stuff, man. In Japan. No, but it ends
the war. I'm interested in winning. I'm interested in stopping
this stuff from happening. I'm interested in protecting my country.
That's my >> The funny thing is is basically none of those
like the examples he just used
would be justifications for innocence. Nobody's even arguing
that these people are innocent. They're arguing we don't know
these people are guilty, right? Like he's basically arguing about
mass civilian casualties, which isn't happening here. Like he's
not even I don't He's not even on the right page. >> My
goal. That's it. This solves that
Shouldn't have been doing it. It's collateral damage. But we
learned uh we learned from that not to do that. If we learn from
that not to do that, then why do we still have nuclear bombs?
You stupid. You stupid. What? What? I don't even know where to
begin. I actually don't even know. I I
Oh my god. But we learned we learned from that not to do that.
If we learned from that not to do that, then why do we still
have nuclear bombs? You stupid. You stupid. What? What? Like
Oh my god. Some of these people like really who is that? There's
a lot of people that don't get this man. Yeah, we've done crazier
things like Japanese internment. Well, I I I don't agree with
that one. That That's one I don't even I don't agree with. Right.
Why? Why? Hold on. Why?
That's really important cuz I I'm pretty sure. Okay. That's important
to know why he wouldn't agree with it. Okay. because there are
reasons he could possibly have that would make sense and be consistent,
but there are also a lot of reasons that I feel like he'd opt
for which are not reasons to be against it for him. >> That's
the same people uh for people on the left against the right.
>> Well, yeah, but I want this to happen through a a democratic
way. I want the government to do it, right? I don't want this
to be vigilantes doing this. I want it to be the government.
So, that's really the difference. Neverland lived happily ever
after. I mean, I think that things are better off that we beat
Nazi Germany and uh Imperial Japan. I think that was a good thing
and I think people are better off. >> Imperial Japan had
lost the war completely. Like Imperial Japan was totally destroyed
by the time they did the nukes. They didn't they wanted to do
the nukes because they'd already lost a lot of people and they
didn't want to spend a 100,000 lives taking the homeland of Japan.
That was that was really what it was. is they said okay this
this like the the ethos of Japan the spirit that animates this
country is unlike anything else that's been faced in history
they will fight to the last like man child in this country if
we don't do something crazy
right also yes yes also
it was a way of signaling to I think so the Soviet Union right
basically like hey don't [__] with us don't don't
come into Western Europe right now okay you don't want to [__]
I think that was a big thing, right? Cuz the Western European
armies weren't really like anything anymore and the Soviets had
their entire war machine mobilized and
I think it was I I think there's a big element there of like
no no you're not going through Western Europe because of that
uh as a matter of fact actually
I think that there are a lot of issues uh things like that happen
and uh yeah it's legal anyways the US laws don't apply in international
waters. People have forgotten that peace needs to be enforced.
Absolutely. But yeah, anyway, I totally support this. I'm a big
fan of it. Uh obviously, innocent people will probably get killed.
That's just a uh I I think in my opinion, it's a necessary consequence
to protecting a country. Every law, every enforcement of a law,
every rule, every enforcement of a rule will have false positives.
Just because you have false positives doesn't mean that you shouldn't
have a rule. Like there are people that are in >> what
what law or rule is this enforcing? in jail for murder, but they
didn't murder somebody. Does that mean we should make murder
against the not against the law? Of course not. So, you have
to accept a this is against like from what I understand the argument
would be this is against the law the US has agreed to uphold.
It's international law, but it is against the law the US has
agreed to uphold. It might even be against US law, as in probably
to do something like this, you would need more oversight than
just a unilateral executive decision to engage in this stuff,
right? It's arguably against both the laws of America and the
law like international law at the same time. >> Degree
of mistakes in order to make any sort of a change or to act in
any sort of an effective way. So that's it. Fair enough. And
and this is just logic like I I I don't like I just think about
this logically. also
his his whole hypothetical there with murder. It's like, okay,
you're comparing a trial that happens that sentences somebody
to murder that has like advocates on both sides of the trial
and a jury of the pe of of your peers who are going to judge
you. The false positive there is far more acceptable to people,
right? The false positive here is like, oh, there's a boat. Pretty
sure we have some intel that it's drug runners. Yeah, let's blow
it up. Right? Like there's nothing there's no insight. There's
no sorry there's no oversight, there's no transparency, there's
nothing as compared to a murder trial which would have all of
those things >> like that's it. Uh I'll read a few comments
but other than that we'll uh we'll move on. But I know there's
a lot of people one year ago uh was never trust the government
now stance you you shift your stance. Never tr one year ago I
said not to trust the government now you shift your stance.
Uh I I don't know you like give me an example like I think we
should trust the government with some things and not with others.
Right? I trust the military to conduct military operations on
illegal drug dealers better than I trust them to manage my data
and be able to see what I'm doing in my house. Like uh I
Okay, so hold on. Let's pull up the uh the AUMF, the authorization
on military force. Okay, this is the this is the pretext that
they're using saying they have the authority to do this. Okay.
Um let's see here. Do I want to use the AI stuff or I just want
like a Wikipedia page? Can I get a wiki page, please?
Right here. The authorization, Hold on. I need I need some music.
The authorization for use of military force, AUMF, is a joint
resolution of the United States Congress, which became law on
September 18th, 2001. Huh. I wonder if something happened like,
let's say, a week before this, that might have led to people
making some bad decisions at this time. What do you guys think?
Do you guys know anything bad that would have happened around
this time? Authorizing the use of the United States Arms armed
forces against those responsible for the September 11th attacks.
The authorization granted the president the authority to use
all necessary and appropriate force against those who whom he
determined planned, authorized, committed or aided the September
11th attacks and who are harbored said persons or groups. Okay.
In this case, the AUMF grants power to the president to determine
both who to target and what actions to take. The AUMF is different
from a declaration of war in that the AUMF is a statutory force
authorization limiting the president's use of full military force
which he would otherwise have in a declaration of war. So apparently
this has continued to be used. Yeah. So this is it's funny cuz
this is what I said is I don't see how this is significantly
different than the pretext we've used. Sorry, we I say we the
US government has used to bomb Afghanistan, Yemen,
um a couple different places. I don't know what the if it was
drone strikes in the other places in Africa, but and it seems
like it's not. It seems like it's the same authority that they're
using to bomb all of these places. And I don't understand like
probably the arguments really should have been happening like
5 10 years ago. Hold on. Uh, Business Insiders reported the AMF
has been used to allow military deployment in Afghanistan, the
Philippines, Georgia, Yemen, Djibouti, Kenya, Ethiopia, Retria,
Iraq, and Somalia. The 2001 AUMF has enabled the US president
to unilaterally launch military operations across the world without
any congressional oversight or transparency for more than two
decades. Between 2018 and 2020 alone, US forces initiated what
it labeled counterterror activities in 85 countries. Of these,
the 2001 AUMF has been used to launch classified military campaigns
in at least 22 countries. So, hold on. What are you saying, Porter
Bellar? There's no AUMF for Venezuela. They're not even claiming
one. Well, hold on. It sounds like they're It sounds like this
must have must have been expanded at some point, right? Since
its passage in 2001, US presidents have interpreted their authority
under the AMF to extend beyond al-Qaeda and the Taliban in Afghanistan
to apply it to other groups as well as other geographic local
due to the acts omission of any specific areas of operation uh
area of operations. The adoption of this law does not require
the persons to be state actors but can include non-state actors
such as individual persons. In December 2016, the office of the
president published a brief interpret uh a brief interpreting
the AUMF as providing congressional authorization for the use
of force against al-Qaeda and other militant groups. Today, the
full list of actors the US military is fighting or believes itself
authorized to fight against under the 2001 AUMF is classified.
Oh, so they're not using the AUMF. Oh, [__] I thought
they Oh, god damn it. They're not even using this. What is this?
Okay, hold on. We will check this. Trump determined the US is
now in a war with drug cartels. Congress is told. A notice calls
the people of the US calls the people the US military recently
killed on suspicion of drug smuggling in the Caribbean Sea unlawful
combatants. Let's give this a quick read. President Trump has
decided that the United States is engaged in a formal armed conflict
with drug cartels his team has labeled terrorist organizations
and that suspected smugglers for such groups are unlawful combatants,
the administration said in a confidential notice to Congress
this week. The notice was sent to several congressional committees
and obtained by the New York Times. It adds new detail to the
administration's thinly articulated legal rationale for why three
US military strikes the president ordered on boats in the Caribbean
Sea last month, killing all 17 people aboard them should be seen
as lawful rather than murder. They're using the self-defense
section of the UN charter. Okay. Mr. Trump's move to formally
deem his campaign against drug cartels as an active armed conflict
means he is cementing his claim to extraordinary wartime powers.
legal specialist say uh said in an armed conflict as defined
by international law, a country can lawfully kill enemy fighters
even when they pose no threat, detain them indefinitely without
trials and prosecute them in military courts. Jeffrey S. born
a retired judge, advocate, lawyer, uh, general lawyer, retired
judge, advocate, general lawyer, I don't know how to read that
title, who is formerly the US, the US Army's senior adviser for
law of war issues, said drug cartels were not engaged in hostilities,
the standard for when there is an armed conflict for legal purposes
against the United States because selling a dangerous product
is different from an armed attack, noting that it is illegal
for the military to deliberately target civilians who are not
directly participating in hostilities, even suspected criminals.
Mr. Korn called the president's move an abuse that crossed a
major legal line. That seems pretty clear. Does it make more
sense why he changed it to the Department of War? No, not really,
cuz they're literally saying it's self-defense. Anyway, there
is uh this is not stretching the envelope, he said. This is shredding
it. This is tearing it apart. And a Kelly, a White House spokeswoman,
said in an email that the president acted in line with the law
of armed conflict to protect our country from those trying to
bring deadly poison to our shores. and he is delivering on his
promise to take on the cartels and eliminate these national security
threats for murdering more Americans.
The Trump administration has called the strikes self-defense
and asserted that the laws of war permitted it to kill rather
than arrest the people on the boats because it said that targets
were smuggling drugs for cartels it is designated as terrorists.
So, it seems like this wouldn't be required if they weren't using
the AUMF.
It's like they they're kind of giving themselves plausible deniability
without citing which authority they're using, right? Or did they
cite the the
you said they cited what? The second amendment, not second Jesus
Christ. Uh article two, the constitution or something, right?
Just it's the incorporation of the executive. Sorry, you have
to forgive me. I didn't take American civics classes, so sometimes
I'm a little slow in this stuff. You guys got to catch me up
a little bit from the chat. All right, I trust you. No, I didn't.
I didn't even think of uh the second amendment, the incorporation
of uh like the executive, the authority granted to the president.
2 minute video on Trump declaring war on the drug cartel. Okay,
give me a second. Trump administration has called the self-defense.
The administration has also stressed that tens of thousands of
Americans die annually from more overdoses. However, the focus
of the administration's attacks has been boats from Venezuela.
The surge of overdose deaths in recent years has been driven
by fentanyl, which drug trafficking experts says says come from
Mexico, not South America. Beyond factual issues, the barebones
argument has been broadly criticized on legal grounds by specialists
in armed conflict law. The notice to Congress, which was deemed
controlled but unclassified information, cites a statute requiring
reports to lawmakers about hostilities involving US armed forces.
It repeats the administration's earlier arguments, but also goes
further with new claims, including portraying the US military's
attacks on boats to be part of a sustained act of conflict rather
than isolated acts of claim self-defense. Hold, let me open up
music. Give me a sec. Give me a sec. Okay, he says part two.
Oh, this is what we're looking at. Okay. Action with respect
to threats to peace, breaches of peace, and acts of aggression.
Nothing in the present charter shall impair the inherent right
of individual or collective self-defense if an armed attack occurs
against a member of the United Nations until the security council
has taken measures necessary to maintain international peace
and security. Measures taken by members in the exercise of this
right of self-defense shall be immediately reported to the security
council and shall not in any way affect the authority and responsibility
of the security council under the present charter to take at
any time such action as it deems necessary in order to maintain
or restore international peace and security.
Okay. Interesting. Interesting. Oh, not this guy. We're looking
at this guy. Okay. Continuing on from here specifically, it says
that Mr. Trump has determined that cartels engaged in smuggling
drugs are non-state armed groups whose actions constitute an
armed attack on the United States and it cites a term from international
law, a non- international armed conflict that refers to a war
with a non-state actor. Okay, I feel like I have enough information
now to say that in some ways, okay, no, it's not quite the same.
I was going to say Trump's like totally taken a page. He he probably
went to BB and was like, "Wait, how do you guys justify what
you're doing?" Wait, hold on. H how do you justify getting rid
of all those people? I got some people I want to get rid of.
Okay. How do you do it? How can you can you give me some tips,
man? You got some tips? Okay. Based upon the cumulative effects
of these hostile acts against the citizens and interests of the
United States and friendly foreign nations, the president determined
that the United States is in a non- international armed conflict
with these designated terrorist organizations. The notice said
these are different kinds of wars and the concept of a non- international
armed conflict developed in the 20th century law in 20th century
law sorry to mean a civil war in one country as opposed to a
war between two or more nation states after the terrorist attacks
on September 11th 2001 when the United States went to war against
al-Qaeda a non-state actor operating across multiple countries
some legal scholars objected that the Bush administration was
stretching the rules to justify using warfare powers against
a group they likened more to a criminal band of pirates but the
Supreme Court found that the conflict with al-Qaeda was a real
war. It blessed as lawful the Bush administration's use of the
wartime power to hold captured members al-Qaeda members in indefinite
detention without trial while saying the government was bound
by the Geneva Conventions to treat such prisoners humanely and
not torture them. The court's reasoning, however, turned on the
fact that al-Qaeda had attacked the United States using hijacked
airplanes as weapons to intentionally kill people and that Congress
had authorized the use of armed force against it. Instead, in
a 2006 ruling, the court also rejected the Bush administration's
first attempt to use military commissions, saying that lawmakers
needed to explicitly authorize them. In this case, the Trump
administration is conflating the trafficking of an illicit consumer
product and associated crime with an armed attack, asserting
in the notice that cartels illegally and directly cause the deaths
of tens of thousands of American citizens each year. But it has
not explained how selling a dangerous substance constitutes a
use of force, and Congress has not authorized the use of any
type of military force against cartels. Obviously, this w you
know if you don't keep it to armed force or armed like attacks
that sort of spirals out in crazy ways like like would um let's
say the Philippines for example, would they have the right to
like blow up American ships transporting tobacco like cigarettes
into their country under the same pretext like oh well cancer
tons of people here these cigarettes are flooded all over our
country. We have to do this. It would, right? They wouldn't ever
do it, but it would give them that kind of that kind of like
pretext. So, obviously, this would be opening like a massive
can of worms if you were to allow people to attack um I guess
people bringing a product into that country. All right. In this
case, the Trump administration is conflating the trafficking.
Oh, no, no, we read this. US government has routinely said it
is engaged in a metaphorical war on drugs, meaning aggressive
law enforcement. Mr. Trump's claim that he can and has put the
country into a literal state of war against drug cartels is important
for legal reasons. Police arrest suspected uh police arrest suspected
drug dealers, it would be a crime to instead sumearily gun them
down. But in an armed conflict, it is lawful to kill combatants
for the opposing force on site. The notice to Congress also justified
the most recent publicly disclosed attack on a boat in which
the US special in which US special operations forces killed all
three people about the vessel on September 15th by calling the
crew unlawful combatants as if they were soldiers on a battlefield.
The vessel was assessed by the US intelligence community to be
affiliated with a designated terrorist organization and at that
time engaged in trafficking illicit drugs which could
on twisters which could ultimately be used to kill Americans.
The notice said this strike resulted in the destruction of the
vessel, the elicit narcotics, and the death of approximately
three unlawful combatants. Guys, we blew up all the evidence.
Okay, we would show you the evidence, but it's kind of, you know,
it's all over the Pacific. No, the Atlantic in this case. It's
all over the Atlantic. All right. The notice to Congress did
not specifically name any of the drug cartels with which Mr.
Trump claims the United States is engaged in an armed conflict.
It also did not specify any standards the administration is using
to determine whether particular suspects have sufficient links
to such groups for the military to kill them. Senator Jack Reed
of Rhode Island, the top Democrat on the Armed Services Committee,
accused Mr. Trump of deciding that he could wage secret wars
against anyone he calls an enemy. The president offered no credible
legal justification, evidence, or intelligence for the strikes,
Mr. Reid said. So, this is a big one is like you should at least
have to be transparent with Congress, right? Like if if not the
American people directly, then absolutely Congress. And Congress,
as far as I know, has not seen any any justification for these
attacks. Drug cartels are despicable and must be dealt with by
law enforcement, he said. But now, by the president's own words,
the US military is engaged in armed conflict with undefined enemies.
He has unilaterally labeled unlawful combatants. And he has deployed
thousands of troops, ships, and aircraft against them. Yet, he
has refused to inform Congress or the public. But Sean Parnell,
the chief Pentagon spokesman, said the Defense Department was
successfully prosecuting his this critical mission in compliance
with both domestic and international law and in accordance with
the law of armed conflict. The department has provided the required
notifications to Congress. Jesus. All right, guys. If you're
just showing up now, we're uh we're going to finish up this article,
then we're on to the court documents. All right, give me a quick
sec. Okay, so Brian Fino
Fino I don't know. Finuka, a former State Department lawyer who
is a specialist in the laws of armed conflict and has criticized
the boat attacks expressed skepticism. Among other things, under
international law, for a non-state entity to be part of an armed
conflict, it must meet the standard of being an organized armed
group, he noted. Not surprised that the administration may have
settled on such a theory to legally backfill their operations,
Mr. Fukane said. I had speculated they might do so. One major
problem, however, is that it is far from clear that whoever they
are targeting is an organized armed group such as the US uh such
that the US could be in an NIA with it. Non
international armed conflict. They define this up here.
Non- international armed conflict. Yes. Okay. Down down down
down.
Not Oh, yes. Mr. Fukane questioned whether the gang the Trump
administration has most talked about targeting Trend Arabwa is
coherent enough to meet this threat. this that threshold. An
intelligence assessment in April, which was declassified and
made public the following month, said the Venezuelan group consisted
of loosely organized cells of localized individual criminal networks
and was so decentralized that it would be difficult for it to
coordinate actions. Oh my god, they're using the Antifa. The
Antifa events for Trend Awa.
You can't make this up. Listen, Trend Ara is more of an
I I can't be the only person who sees that. That's funny to me.
Okay. That's just a goofy thing. That's funny.